repose sur une fine couche de glace qui
fond rapidement une image qui frôle la
réalité les impacts des changements
climatiques sont plus violents plus
fréquents quantité et dans l'avenir ils
seront plus nombreux au bord des accusés
l'activité humaine si on continue sur
les trajectoires actuelles on aura des
températures on sera dans plus de 3
degrés à la fin du siècle ce qui veut
dire que les régions qui sont déjà
vulnérables sont des régions où il y
aura le plus de morts près de la moitié
de l'humanité et hautement vulnérable
devant la planète qui s'embrasse
annoncent les scientifiques des
populations souvent déjà confrontées à
de l'insécurité alimentaire et des
pénuries d'eau
en Afrique et en Asie la mortalité est
liée aux inondations sécheresses et
tempêtes et 15 fois plus élevées qu'il y
a 10 ans
climatique est en marche mais le GIEC
propose un guide pour la désamorcer un
guide de survie pour l'humanité un guide
que les politiques devront suivre à la
lettre il n'y a plus de place selon eux
pour de nouveaux projets d'extraction
pétrolière ou de gaz les projets
existants menacent déjà les objectifs de
l'accord de Paris de contenir le
réchauffement à 1,5 degrés il faut
cesser de financer de supporter et même
d'approuver toute énergie fossile et de
rediriger cet argent-là vers les
solutions qui existent mais l'espoir est
encore permis selon les scientifiques
les outils technologiques existent et
sont apportées de main pour les
investisseurs il représente des
bénéfices financiers considérables puis
le les énergies plus vertes à
sérieusement chutées - 85% pour
l'énergie solaire et les batteries
lithium et de 55% pour l'éolien les pays
doivent agir maintenant le gouvernement
canadien lui maintient son engagement à
ne plus souvent mentionner les énergies
fossiles nous avons pris l'engagement
d'éliminer les subventions combustibles
fossiles deux ans plus tôt que nos
partenaires
mais ne dit pas s'il donnera ou non son
approbation a de nouveau projet
d'extraction ici Elisa serrer
Radio-Canada Montréal